so it's my pleasure to welcome Gary
Vaynerchuk
thank you what I really want to do is QA
so what I'm gonna do here is talk for as
little as possible to create some
context for those that don't know me and
to just add some value because I think
sometimes people get worried that Q&A is
just mailing it in but I really really
do believe that so much of what I talk
about right now is available free on
YouTube or somewhere else and so that
you can watch at any point and I think
we don't get the time to hang out that
often and so I will go to that a little
bit earlier than maybe expected but I'll
start off by saying this first of all
it's really exciting for me to be here
obviously as a CEO of vaynermedia as I'm
kind of planning out where our offices
can and will be not only in the US but
globally you know obviously we started
with New York and then we went to San
Francisco and then LA and and it's been
interesting to see how many people you
know I probably get asked somewhere
between 15 and 20 times a week
why Chattanooga for number four and it's
really it's really exciting for me to be
here this morning got up at 3:15 in the
morning got stuck in Charlotte by the
way Mickey I know you love Charlotte but
screw Charlotte
but uh but driving into town it was
funny it uh it reminded me the first
time I was here a couple years ago for
my book signing tour and and literally
just to myself because I speak to myself
a lot it's a kind of a weird thing I
just said this is why Chattanooga right
I remember the feeling I had when I was
there and so thank you so much for
having me and thank you for so much for
being such a phenomenal city that I know
so few people at this point know what's
really going on here and very honestly
much like Facebook and Twitter and uber
I've benefited from being right on the
outcome years later and I don't think
I've been more confident or positive on
a bet that I've made in my career as I
have on this remarkable city
it's funny this this this town it
reminds me it's kind of like it's kind
of like my venture right like the thing
I probably want to talk about is I just
want to implore every single person in
here as we're talking about Startup
Weekend and the vibes that come along
with it I don't know you know and I
recently put out a video that's been my
most watched video of my career it was
actually targeted towards 40 to 80 year
old entrepreneurs so for a long time
I've been really kind of talking to you
know kids and things of that nature and
I realized hey I'm not a kid and be you
know the fact of the matter is is this
is the greatest time ever to build a
business and it's because of the
internet you know I don't know if you're
paying attention but the Internet at the
consumer Internet is really only 20
years old people only really started
getting on the internet during Windows
95 and I know it came out earlier but
that was weird nerdy it's hanging out
like this is this is what normal people
started really coming on the web and so
to think that it's only 20 years old and
to think about the impact it's had on
our society already it's just starting
and I think much like for me you know if
there is no internet or if internet was
coming 20 years later if I grew up in
the era that my parents grew up in uh
and I was running a wine business in New
Jersey there would have been no internet
opportunity for me to use YouTube to
change the course of my career there
would have been no Twitter to change the
course of my career and start getting
attention what's interesting is I I
think of the Internet in a couple ways
one as really the middle man right I
mean I think it's if you're in the
middle of any business the Internet has
become that platform but more
importantly it's become the tool that
has given every single person and that
bat see the thing I'm scared about and
the thing that I'm excited about is
actually the exact same thing there are
a lot of people in this room whether in
their 20s or in their 80s that are
excited about starting their own
business what's happened in the last
five to seven years is that
entrepreneurship has gotten sexy like
when I was a kid you know first of all I
don't even use the word entrepreneur and
it's fun to see some of the 30 and ups
shake their head because entrepreneur
only 15 years ago meant you were a loser
it meant you had ideas and probably
lived at your dad's house right so so
entrepreneurship was not a very
attractive word and it's been
interesting and fun for me because I am
an entrepreneur I used to say
businessman but now I'm comfortable
saying entrepreneur and it's been fun to
watch the word evolve but it's really
it's actually the same the excitement
has that I have the equal reaction to
the concern here's what I mean by that
this phenomenon of the Internet the
reason and forget about the speed of it
and that's incredible in this town wins
on that but I mean just the at-bat is
the reason that a start-up or an
individual from this town has the same
at-bat and chance as somebody from New
York or LA or London or Paris it's just
the truth you may not think it people
love to dwell and look at the negative
but the truth is let me just remind you
things some of the hottest companies in
the world Pinterest was started in
Pennsylvania Facebook was started in
Boston like these things are not just
started in Silicon Valley they can make
these things happen I was in
unfortunately because I didn't invest in
the angel route I was in the room when
uber was invented in Paris you know
obviously they were SF Star they were
San Francisco entrepreneurs but Travis
was from LA and Garret was from Canada
and so this stuff can happen anywhere
the problem is and I really want to
speak about this for a second and I have
I think for the few that know who I am
I'm nowhere close to Debbie Downer but I
just want to I want to draw a line in
the sand while we're talking about
startup week and I want to talk about
self-awareness self-awareness is
massively important if I could wish
anything on anybody besides health it
would be self-awareness I think the
reason that I've had a happy life and
some success is because of
self-awareness it it allows me to
recognize the 99 percent of things that
I suck crap at and what's happening
right now is because it's so easy to get
in that bat and to start a business and
to be a start-up founder so many people
are doing it right that same gift is
actually potentially not a curse because
it's a tremendous experience and it's
not like you're doing anything wrong but
I do implore everybody as you get
excited about this week and everything
that's going on and definitely what's
gonna start happening in this town to
really give a lot of thought to what
you're good at
and what you're not good at and and and
I implore you to really if you're lucky
enough to have self-awareness or if
you're lucky enough to be comfortable
with who you are and you're not in the
business of lying to yourself and I
think everybody is a little bit
including myself but if you're good at
it
I really implore you to triple down and
quadruple down and 7x down on your
strengths I actually think the reason
this town is gonna win is for a lot of
reasons but one that stands out is if
you don't buy into your own hype as it
starts growing over the next half decade
and things of that nature then you have
a chance I'm betting on what you bring
to the table I think all the cliche
things you know I think about
stereotypes and cliches I'm fascinated
by them because they're there because
there's a whole lot of truth in them
right yet we don't want to deal with
that truth it doesn't feel politically
correct and things of that nature but
what what I've been thinking a lot about
with this office with the Vayner team
and this town and and you know my
excitement to see what kind of startups
pop up from here because very honestly
one of the biggest reasons I bet on this
town was not only because I thought it
was a good place for an office but I
believe in the talent and the underbelly
of the fire of some of the leading
entrepreneurs in this town as a gateway
drug for me to get into good deals I I'm
completely convinced that there will be
a remarkable multi hundred million
dollar business that starts here and I
feel like having an office here and
having a presence here and being a name
in the game here gives me a better
chance of being an investor in that
company or being involved in that
company and so the the thing that I
wanted to come here besides my QA and
that's really what I want to do what I
wanted to say is bet on who you are way
too many towns and I do one of the big
strategies I have in my book tours when
I speak is to go to non New York LA
Chicago cities right first of all I'm in
the business of selling things
especially for big companies and most
big companies sell stuff in not New York
LA and San Francisco
most of them sell it in a lot of other
places and I think a lot of people that
live in New York like myself a lot of my
contemporaries and my friends that live
the bubbles of SF la New York don't
really realize what the hell's going on
in actual America and live in their own
bubble so that's cool and that's a fun
thing to say to you because you're like
yeah but but I'm actually concerned in
the other direction for this same room
for the same thing which is while
everybody gets excited when I say that
when I'm in Omaha and Kansas and I win
all these places they equally then when
I leave and become friends with them and
I watch their behavior they try to act
like New York NSF and LA especially when
they play this game and I think that's a
mistake
I think betting on your strengths and
understanding who you are and what you
can service and and really the best
thing in the world to do in my opinion
if you're starting a business is to
scratch your own itch when you scratch
your own itch or fix your own problem
you tend to build a really good business
because you know exactly what you're
solving for instead of sitting right now
and think about how am I gonna start the
next picture app like Instagram the
greatest thing you could ever do and
this is why I think I'm a very good
salesman I just live my life and I
listen for all the talking I do I do a
whole lot of listening and a whole lot
of watching of the people that are
important to me in my world and then I
react to that and then I react to it and
I think one of the great things that you
could be doing is actually thinking
about your own pain points day in and
day out on ways that you could solve a
problem
literally uber was solved by affluent
people saying huh wouldn't be cool to
have your own black car all the time you
know like and when you think about those
kind of things you start understanding
the opportunities at hand and so one of
the things that I hope to inspire at
least one person in this room it deploys
self-awareness to deploy the thought of
how do I solve my day in and day out
problems and what kind of companies and
opportunities are gonna be built out of
the DNA of this city that are different
than let's say the two or three cities
that get talked a lot about in
technology today my friends this is the
second Industrial Revolution like I just
want you to know especially for the 20
and 30 year olds in this crowd because I
as a 40 year old soon in November and a
month holy crap [ __ ]
and the people that are older than me we
didn't get as lucky as you did this is
this is the generation like this is the
sweet spot this is the land grab this is
what happens everybody's got their own
generations and their own great things
and their own bad things if you just
want to talk about entrepreneurship if
you just want to talk about having an
app that to build something for yourself
that you own and do something that you
like this is better than 1987 this is
better than 1974 this is better than
1963 and the one thing that I asked you
to do is to not look back and regret
that you wavered on the moment that was
available to you the only thing that's
not fun the only thing you regret is the
things that you don't do it's just the
way it is like even if you think of
random dumb stuff like not asking out
that person in high school or so there's
stuff lingers it's the stuff that you
don't do that bothers you and so for the
purebred entrepreneurs in here that
haven't decided to make that leap or
take that at bat I implore you to do so
right away because this window closes -
it's just supply and demand as you get
more and more entrepreneurs and as more
and more people do it more and more
at-bats fall off the stream it was a lot
a lot easier to start social media sites
in two thousand three four five six and
seven that are is now because nine
thousand photo social apps hit the App
Store every day and so if you hear that
and you hear the last little part of my
rant would just know yourself I'm trying
to point you in a direction of where the
opportunity is because there is so much
white space still available to build in
businesses yet people are really
attracted to the one or two billion
dollar exits and they think they need
two guys for every Instagram there's
80,000 insta shits
so everybody's chasing these unicorns
these once-in-a-lifetime do you do you
know how phenomenal it sounds to your
grandparents if you told them that you
built a business that you own that you
run that you like doing and you make
$200,000 a year do you know what kind of
Nirvana that actually is in the scheme
of things and so we are not rounding
this entrepreneurial startup
conversation and the right thing we're
grounding it in these headlines of the
five or six things snapchat Facebook
Instagram Eber and we're not talking
about the tens of thousands of
opportunities there are if you actually
take a step back understand what's
happening try to build something around
your pain point like your pain point
might be your three kids piss you off
all the time like that's a real pain
point right like I don't know create an
uber for like baby sitters like you like
you know like like there is so many ways
to build businesses and if you just sit
back right now and think about how much
money you make double that amount and
then think about being able to do
something on your own terms now all of a
sudden you've ground yourself in a
totally different conversation than this
weird need to like be the next sucks
right or like change the world or things
of that nature and so I'm looking for
practicality I'm looking for real
practicality because practical business
building has never been easier and the
best part is it's never been cheaper for
so many of you in this room one of the
things you can use as an excuses oh
there's not as much money here as there
is in San Francisco in New York I can't
raise as much money good you know many
people are about to raise a crapload of
money and lose it all in which money is
about to be lost the amount of money
that's about to be lost on all the fund
raising that's gone on for the last four
years is disgusting you know another
thing it's good to learn how to build a
business that actually makes [ __ ]
money
yeah it's good the amount of companies
I'm watching young kids with ideas raise
three million dollars and deploy no
practicality and actually building a
business is scary and then they're gonna
lose all those people's money and you
know what the reaction is it was good
experience yeah for you I'm pissed I
lost my 50k and so we pissed I work real
hard so I I think that um I think if
there's any energy that I can bring it's
that I'm here and veiners here and we're
here because we believe in the DNA and
the culture and the infrastructure that
is here we're not here to like make it
look like all the other places and I
think it's interesting to me because as
I've been auditing the conversations on
Twitter from this town and the startups
and thought leaders and the people in it
I think weirdly as an outsider I believe
in it more than a lot of people that are
in it and so I think that's interesting
and I hope that this little chat makes
you think about that it may be of a
different direction
and and I really really really wish all
of you nothing but health and happiness
thank you
so cool given that it's like a smaller
room and probably has really good
acoustics I wanted to go short and just
kind of tell it like I really wanted to
get that off my chest because I think
it's an interesting conversation but I
know that like you know 20 to 50% of you
probably have context on me I mean I'm
more than willing to answer any
questions about you know I've invested
in over 100 businesses I've run two
businesses that I've grown from small
bases to large bases quickly I'm in it
advertising anything anything I can
answer let's just go into Q&A who wants
it who's got a question good-looking
dude with the beard jockey and horses
right some commonalities yeah there is
no I don't have a common thread the
truth is I married my wife eighteen
seconds into our first date right and so
in my mind and I told her a couple hours
later and we were married within the
year of meeting and uh and that's how I
feel about entrepreneurs there's a I
know it's fun my brother doesn't go to
my keynotes anymore because I think I
bore him but he happens to be here and
he's in the back and I know he's gonna
hear this I always talk about this one
boxers name is Julian Jackson he was a
boxer from the 80s and I just one agent
was like 15 I would just make him watch
Julian Jackson boxing videos on YouTube
over and over so that's why I mentioned
AJ uh he said something after a fight he
he was he was uh he said something that
was really interesting to me he said
they said something like how do you know
did it use there's just this feeling in
my right hand he's like he basically
said I have feeling in right hand if I
punch and face no man get up and and
that's kind of how I am with business
that's why I've always kind of
associated myself with Julian Jackson
the mid-80s boxer which is whether I
look at a business or I go in for a sale
or a meet somebody I I don't know what
their commonalities are people try to
gain me you know they watch 150 episodes
of askgaryvee or all my keynotes
and they try to feed me stuff that uh
they think I'm gonna respond to their a
hustler they'll die before losing all
those things the problem is they don't
realize I'm not listening to a word
they're saying
I'm just going by what I feel and so I
think a lot of our culture at Vayner is
the same way it's just like I live on
that and so um I don't know if there's
commonalities there's clearly some
commonalities i I think intent if my
heart believes that they have the right
intent I can be swayed but there's no
words that are gonna make me feel that
way
thanks questions is certain to blue
thank you for some of you don't know in
2006 less than a year after YouTube was
out I started a wine show called Wine
Library TV for my business the first
episode I sat down I went in fully with
the intentions of this bean QVC then I
was gonna sit there and I was gonna sell
wine cuz that's what I did for a living
and then the most insane thing happen I
mean I've never done any performing
speaking I'm a 30 year old dude at this
point like at 30 you kind of think you
know you kind of think you know yourself
right like I'd never like I didn't like
doing speeches in class I definitely
didn't do like performances I didn't do
TV I didn't so it was weird to me what
happened it was just one of those things
like $300 best five video camera sitting
in front of me up just like this I
remember it like yesterday I'm looking
right at it I'm about to sell these
three bottles of wine and that red light
goes on it's something weird happened
within a second I was like huh this is
gonna live forever
I really better be careful and not be
full of [ __ ] and so what happened was
literally from episode one it
transformed into me just giving my
advice on those wines regardless of how
much was downstairs and to answer a
question directly you know I was so
convinced that YouTube was gonna be huge
and that video blogging was gonna be a
real thing and that this could arbitrage
television over the next decade that I
just wanted to be part of the legacy I
didn't need any feedback
I was so bought in back to that feeling
that the one great thing I have that I
really hope my kids have is just utter
blind conviction when I'm in I'm in
period and the story like I don't waver
and I mean really don't waver and so
everybody could leave this town and I'd
still be here like when I buy in I buy
in and so I I know that's weird
um so I wasn't looking for much I was I
was just executing something that I knew
and look it was 18 months before I mean
18 months is a long time of pumping out
video day after day and back then I
didn't travel five days a week 18 months
and not much was happening it just but I
knew it was there and then it's sort of
clicking Gemma next to you
it's coming better it's getting better
I've lost 24 pounds I'm feeling good
about it but abs are tough when you're
old Mike said I'd be in great shape
they're there but that last bit of fat
as a beast you know it's funny thanks
for bringing that up
I know no no no no I actually I actually
think it's a good transition my I would
tell you that my mom who knows me better
than anybody I have so much of her DNA
we're just super simpatico we literally
don't talk every day first a pair that
she should talk every day
because we almost talk every day without
talking it's crazy it's so scary I don't
even want to tell you the weird story
you know what I'm gonna tell you I've
never told this story in my life I'm on
family vacation and I find out like cuz
I'm Eastern European my family's weird
like my mom goes in for procedures we
don't even know she's going to the
hospital right like so she's going to
have like some minor thing right I think
I'll call it off see nothing crazy at
all
I'm literally on vacation with my my
with my wife's family in Naples Florida
I'm just literally laying listening to
music working like scrolling on espn.com
whatever literally literally out of
nowhere I'm laying there and I get up
and I walk to the other side this is so
weird to say all that like I go to the
other side of the pool and I just sit
down and I start telling my mom to wake
up I soar to God I'm like mom you need
to wake up mom wake up
and so that was it like that was a story
couple hours later like I call like mic
my dad's like everything's cool right
cool
and a story until two years later we're
on a family vacation in Puerto Rico I'm
just sitting with my mom we're talking
about something something gets brought
up and it gets brought up that she was
really not responding well to the
medicine and she she like just wasn't
getting up and out of nowhere she gets
up and she starts asking for
me I don't know why I'm telling you this
I think I'm telling you this because the
thing that is probably weighing on me
more than anything right now in my life
is that we know nothing about the brain
I don't have you know this we know
jack-shit about the brain and I'm
completely weirded out by that because I
think I could do so so I'll give you
another weird one and I'm going very zen
on you seven years ago I decided I would
never get sick again I haven't been sick
yet it's crazy I travel so much I don't
wash my hands like I'm telling you so so
I was like how the [ __ ] did I get there
I got it out of all the things I've done
in my life
my mom is most proud that I've been able
to execute on getting my health together
and working out and eating properly
because it doesn't come natural to me
and it's the first thing I've done in my
life I was a DNF student my whole life
because I just didn't come natural to me
and I punted it and I pumped everything
I started this talk by telling you to
bet on your strengths I very much
believe in that believe in it more than
anybody I believe I'm betting in her
strengths I think the society and our
world tells us to fix all our vows laws
and I think we waste enormous times
amounts of money and energy trying to
fix things that only have a little bit
of growth in them while not tripling
down on our strengths but it's funny you
always evolve you change the points of
view I'm so taken aback myself that I
figured out the system that works for me
that it's giving me ambition to work on
other things because I'm surprised I've
been able to like and listen I'm only a
year 1/2 in but I figured it out by the
way real quick for anybody's trying to
figure out their health for me what I
figured out was I was not accountable to
myself I was not self-motivated so I got
to a financial place and this is not
practical for most people where I hired
a full-time person who's in charge of my
health he just follows me around he just
you know he's in Canada right now
waiting for me cuz I have to go there
and speak tomorrow like literally so I I
just figured out that I had to be
accountable to somebody else so not
everybody can afford hiring full-time
health person but maybe another person
in your life or some other weird hack or
maybe you create a company that only
charges a certain amount
to have another human being worth follow
you around and so we can make this whole
conversation go full circle thanks ma'am
yes dear yes such a good question you
know what's so funny I've been thinking
about this a lot and so I figured out my
first hack and I'm getting some good
emails on this first of all it's a hard
one
right but I do have a recommendation I
think you need to grab the 7 to 10
people 3 5 9 that are closest to you in
the world and when I say closest not
just your mom or dad or sister or
brother but weirdly enough you know like
the person you sit next to at work for
the last eight years like people that
you spend the most time with and then
you have to have the weirdest
conversation you've ever had with them
because you have to set up the
conversation by telling them you've got
to make them feel safe cuz you've got to
make them feel safe to tell you the
truth which is very scary when you care
about somebody that's very scary but you
tell them that you're basically trying
to figure yourself out and you need the
truth what are you best at what do you
worst at and it's been interesting I've
been getting I've been I wrote an
article about this and talked about it
and it's been interesting to get the
feedback like people have been really
able to get people to tell them the
truth by really working hard on the
first 20 minutes of the conversation
saying look I know you don't wanna hurt
my feelings look I know you love me look
I get it
I promise I promise I promise I won't be
mad I know you don't believe me but I
promise that right build it build it
build it because if you can get that
truth you're now asking the market there
you know and that's what you're trying
to figure out the market tells you what
you're good at the market the world the
game most people don't want to believe
what they're good at and what they're
bad at see the problem is everybody is
romantic people want to be something
more than recognizing what they are and
so for me in business there's like the
problem with business and that theory is
the market doesn't care right like like
the world doesn't care that you you were
born a minority or an immigrant or have
no money or in a town that doesn't have
internet or it just
doesn't care it's the market right and
so you either dwell on it or you attack
it or you settle into somewhere in the
middle but I do think the best way to
attack it is to know what you're best at
I really do believe that and some of the
things that you're best at aren't that
interesting right like like if I didn't
have if I didn't have sales - might be a
guidance counselor I mean you know a
camp counselor like like you know like I
like to listen I just figured out how to
use that to sell to and so I think you
have to give permission to the people
closest to you to hurt your feelings and
tell you the truth and then have the
audacity and ability to act on that
information yeah yes sir that's a good
question so I think there's two things
going on I think I think I think
valuations are way too high on the early
stage it's literally any kid with any
idea is able to get a five six million
dollar valuation for their business it's
it's so ludicrous it's uncomfortable on
the flip side the reason it's happening
is while this let's say the bubble
bursts right let's say there and by the
way let's define a bubble bursting
something happens that forces Wall
Street to cut Facebook's value in half
which is then as a trickle down because
you can't be worth X if Facebook is
worth Y and it just trickles all the way
down right let's say that happens here's
the problem and why smart people are
staying in it still isn't stopping the
Second Industrial Revolution during this
period we are living through a bubble
while we're equally living through tons
of companies that are gonna be invented
tomorrow that'd be worth a fortune so
you have to navigate through that which
is very very difficult what I would tell
you is and I've been telling myself this
guy's the first three things I invested
over Facebook excuse me I'll give it an
order Twitter Tumblr and Facebook I've
gotten progressively
dumber and and here's why what I
invested in those things I just bet on
things that I knew were sure bets like I
don't even think that I was investors
like these things are gonna be worth
more I can get in let me get in like I
didn't call myself an investor and when
you become an investor you start
changing the rules you start deploying
different things you don't take them for
face value of what they are you start
thinking about other exits or betting on
that entrepreneur in the future or all
these other things you could be doing
and so I would say the best piece of
advice I'm giving myself and my homies
is let's go back to when we really just
bet on it like it is
her startup going to be able to handle a
cash flow crisis an on second round of
funding the reason so many companies are
about to go out of business is when the
funding is not there and they're not
making money you go out of business and
so and so I would say that you don't
punt you don't stay in the sidelines in
wait four years for it to come back you
just become much smarter about your
investments more practical and that's
what I'm trying to do yeah yes sir in
the back my content thank you
so thanks um you know I think I reverse
engineer the crowd right so and I just I
really gave a lot of thought to what I
wanted to say to this specific crowd the
things that you see online a lot of time
are very public big marketing speeches
and those are the things unfortunately
in those places where I want to be on
the record of the current state of
marketing I'm not gonna change what I'm
gonna say for the appeasement of the
YouTube viewing audience because I'm
scared because I want to be correct
historically right so you see a lot of
that stuff I think there's a lot of
stuff running through my mind the reason
I like Q&A is cuz you're gonna get
different stuff because I get to be a
counter-puncher instead of saying the
things that are top of mind so one of
the you know one of the reasons I'm
trying to one of the reasons I started
the askgaryvee show was to freshen up my
content to have my audience push me in
new directions which has happened right
because I talk about a lot of things
plus I evolve right I'm a father of two
now there's just different things going
on I you know when I first hit the scene
Wine Library was a big success but
vaynermedia has gone from 30 to almost
600 employees in the last four years
that's a new thing I can talk about from
an HR and a staffing and an
organizational thing so you know it's
funny
your real answer is because I try
because I don't want to mail it in
because I have so many friends who've
been successful and they're giving the
same presentation for the last four
years and it's not bringing value to
anybody that sees it a second time and
I'm weirdly obsessed I think it's my ego
I desperately want people to continue to
come and see me speak and come and I
want to be like one of those awesome
bands they're like I've seen him nine
times you know and so and so I think I
think unlike music I think you've got to
keep it fresh it's tough to go to the
hits over and over what's the ROI of
your mother
you know like a so like I you know I
think so I think I think it's because I
try it's because I've got plenty to say
I've got a lot of things I speak about
the stuff I know and and that's why this
QA is so important
because I'm able to go in a different
direction but it comes down to intent
yeah I think a lot of people want to
just cash they're speaking check-in and
I want to be around for a long time
Thanks
yes sir
hey man yes this is a question I'm gonna
tell you why my perception of lacking
fear is so real it's because I fear
something so much I fear the health and
well-being of my family so much and I
mean crippled by it hence why you're a
grown-ass man and you get up during a
vacation and go to some weird corner and
pray for your mom to wake up you know I
am so fearful of the well-being of the
10 to 15 people in my life
it is so disproportionately the most
important thing to me in the world that
it just makes everything else so easy
you know the thought of losing all my
money this is gonna get weird is is so
weirdly exciting because I know I have
the talent to rise back up as a phoenix
and be like I told you [ __ ]
because trust me if I lost everything
there be plenty people that would be
happy to write that story that's what
happens when you roll with a little
bravado and so and so it's interesting I
thought that would go away when I had
the kids but this is why it's super
important to marry the right person
right like I'm good
I come from zero like like Rocky 17 or
wherever he went back to zero like it
was a [ __ ] movie and nobody liked it I
was like this is the best like I'm like
you know like some like like weird to
the point where like sometimes when they
do things I'm like am i sabotaging
myself on purpose to play out this weird
narrative that I really want you know
and I thought once having kids that
would change and it has to some degree
but not really and I think then that's
how it plays out on the yang right which
is I I'm so into my feelings I dream of
buying the Jets or having somebody say
this is the this is it this was the guy
he was the best entrepreneur of this
generation and and then I think about
that being anointed on me and then
getting a phone call and hearing that my
mom died in the car accident I do this
to myself and then I see how I feel and
since I feel awful well then why in the
world would I get caught so up in the
financial or other things and so in that
place and in plenty places I'm not I had
jump acient I'm worried about being
bitter one day because I do wait and I'm
patient I try to provide more value than
I receive and so there's vulnerabilities
where I'm aware of but boy I'm super not
scared when it comes to business first
of all I've been doing it my whole life
I've always been good at it I'm good
like I can I can go garage saling in
Chattanooga this weekend and make 500
bucks on eBay so like like I'm gonna be
fine but it's because I'm so scared of
something else
right what's your question like two or
three right yeah sure yeah it's awesome
okay
yes yes I there's a lot of ways I think
about work-life balance it is clearly my
biggest challenge of my life because
there is only 24 hours in a day there's
a and I have a lot of different
variables we all have different
variables my dad I love my dad more than
I love breathing and I didn't even see
my dad until I was 14 he was never home
because we were poor and he had to build
the American dream so I'm sure that I'm
affected by the fact that I have this
incredible relationship predicated on
old-school you know the new school is
like we're in a very politically correct
new school world everybody's got to do
everything about everything and
everything right like like it's like
it's all vanilla all the time and you
look back at the generations before us
and there's plenty of people that are
happy and did well and you know a lot of
us got smacked my mom smacked me in the
mouth like Lizzy's like you know me she
was getting a little rambunctious I'm
like let's punch her in her [ __ ] face
like like like you know like I don't
know like I think so one
I'm definitely affected by the
old-school Eastern European thing for
sure on the flip side I don't want that
for my kids I do want to be there I want
to be there selfishly like it's stunning
to me how many things I'm I haven't
missed any of the school big things and
this recitals and everything I'm pumped
I'm like jeez I'm really you know
everybody so listen because I put out so
much content I think another thing you
may notice is it's almost impossible to
find pictures of my kids right so all
these social me that everybody's putting
on plenty
you know kids content gets good
engagement you know and so on the flip
side I don't my wife and I have decided
we're not going down that path you know
I don't want to put that pressure on my
kids if they want to I think my
daughter's gonna want it she's already
like this summer she's like when am I
gonna be on the askgaryvee
I'm like alright I know where this DNA
is but I don't want to make those
choices for her right and so we've
decided the parents a different way and
I'm very out there and so because I
don't talk about that part of my life
people get a misperception of how much
time I'm spending on that people don't
know that on Wednesday from 9 to 11
primetime hustle hours I'll be at a
school function you know they don't know
that and I respect that I'm not mad at
people for not knowing because I
recognize I don't story tell that to the
public world and I do story tell it's
3:00 a.m. I'm going and so you know I I
do the best I can just like every single
other person here right there's a you
know if you don't if you're not in love
with yourself it's gonna be really hard
to deploy a lot of love to your children
so I'm very conscious of doing what I
want to do for me too and it's just a
constant tug-of-war and as they get
older you have to adjust like I'm
adjusting in the same way with my health
I've been talking a lot about coming
home at 5:00 p.m. every day that I'm in
New York to see them for an hour because
they're just different they're older
there's things that I'm gonna have to
all adjust but uh back to the theme of
this talk I know where my heart's at I
know my intent you know and I'm I won't
be perfect and there'll be a big deal in
three years that takes me away too much
or things of that nature but but I fight
you know I fight yes sir yeah
yes
yes
you know I think you know the answer of
what I'm gonna say I don't think it has
anything to do with what I'm gonna say I
think I think it's gonna come down to
what's gonna happen their lives right
like I'm so blessed that for whatever
reason the way I communicate gets people
to do things right it's funny I really
got scared in 2010 11 12 when I started
getting internet famous for being like a
motivational speaker I really I really
shut down like I understood it was
happening I understood I have that in me
but one of the biggest reasons I wanted
to do vaynermedia all in was to remind
myself and the market that I was a
business builder that the reason people
should listen to my business advice is
because I build them you know and so so
I I try to put out a lot of content on
this subject matter it's why I do a damn
show every day that I'm in New York for
20 minutes to try to give people an orde
star meaning don't take my advice here's
one person doing it this way
here's his perspective use your
self-awareness to navigate around that
and so look I mean there's you know I
tell my closest friends things like you
know dying at 50 sucks you know or or
you know you're never gonna be able to
go backwards you know like like one of
the things I do a lot is look at my kids
baby pictures because you're just like
for anybody who has a young children
it's like and a lot of people I could
tell by the faces in the crowd you've
lived through it but you just blink and
it's over right life goes fast like I
still think it's senior year of high
school in my head you know like like and
so um I try to give perspective I live
in a very pretty head send a very big
like all in perspective world that's why
I don't get that's a little bit of my
fear thing - it's just so up here I'm so
not stressed like I always tell my team
it doesn't mean that much it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter it's not that
big of a deal it's just cuz it's not cuz
it's not and so yeah but everybody's got
to do their thing you know alright fine
thank you thank you so much so happy to
be here thank you thank you so much
thank you thank you
you